Researchers have set up a system
that lets them see mutations in living cells
and follow the cells’ fates.
Good, bad, or neutral---
spontaneous mutations are not easy to detect
in a living system.
But there are important unanswered questions
about how mutations are distributed
and how common they are.
This information makes it possible
to use the mutation rate of organisms
to look back in time to see when
two related species diverged.
In this view,
the mother cells are along the top of a micro-fluidic
chip,
so-named because narrow channels
control the liquid’s flow in very specific ways.
The offspring bud off and
expand into the tiny tubes,
each cell pinched off from its progenitor.
Newly made cells
are whisked away by liquid at the bottom of the tube.
Bacteria are red and
replication error machinery--markers for mutation-
are the yellow dots.
Researchers followed cells over 200 generations
to look for mutations and
the effects those mutations had.
They were able to calculate the rate of deadly mutations --
at about 1% --
much lower than expected.
They also found that mutations occur regularly
in individual cells--
they all get mutations
at about pretty much the same rate,
regardless of stress level--
and that mutations are less detrimental
to the bacteria than expected.
This new technique tracking mutations in single cells
could be used in cancer research or
to explore different mutation patterns in
different tissues.